[Music]
whoops
hello and welcome to i'd like to know my
name is c.a murray and this is our
question and answer program
where we get to answer your questions
from the word of god and it gives us an
opportunity to do what we love to do and
that is study the word of god i'm in the
company of pastor daniel miranda to my
right
and our illustrious pastor stephen bohr
to my left
and i haven't been with these guys for a
little while and it is a great pleasure
to study the word of god with them and
to answer your questions and to be part
of this wonderful wonderful show that we
love so much it is really one of our
favorites should you like to get in on
the fun should you like to be a part of
this program you can send your questions
to tv
at some tv that's s-u-m-t-v dot o-r-g tv
at some tv dot o-r-g as you can see we
have an impressive stack of questions
here so if you don't hear them this week
or you don't hear it next week we're
coming to it we'll get to it it's going
to take us a little while because we've
got a lot of questions and a lot of
answers and we like to give each
question do wait we don't want to rush
through or say something that you may
not understand so we're going to take
our time with the questions because some
require a little more time and we have
promised you
always to give you an answer from the
word of god if an answer can be found in
the word of god
to tell you the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth of the word of
god that is our promise that is our
pledge so
we make that pledge to you and we will
do our very best to keep that pastor boy
if you would
open with prayer we'd like to pray
before we go into the word then we'll
launch out
with our first question
let's pray
father in heaven we thank you
that in your word
we find answers to the deepest questions
that come to our mind
we're thankful that we are able to
freely
open your holy book amen to find
guidance for our lives
and we ask that as we
attempt to answer this very important
question today
that your holy spirit
who inspired the scriptures
will be present with us
to give us clarity of thought
and allow us to speak clearly
so that those who are watching will be
able to understand amen we thank you for
the privilege of prayer and for the
promise that you will be with us
because we ask it in the g in jesus name
amen
all right you're looking to me
okay here we have the question
and this is probably going to take the
better part if not all of the session
today okay
this question comes i don't know if i'm
pronouncing it correctly cebeso
kalaluka
and it doesn't say where this person
lives oh algeria
says
algeria okay and this is the question
in matthew 12 40
we find the idea of three days and three
nights
just as jonas
was in the belly of the womb
so shall the son of man be in the heart
of the earth
question number one what is the meaning
of heart of the earth
is it in the tomb
second question
if it means tomb
then how do we calculate the three days
evening and morning
to show that christ really rose
on sunday
some say three days means he rose on
monday
please help me understand
god bless you for the lives for the live
streams
they are really a blessing to me and
keep me busy
thank you so much
so that's the question
let me back into this uh
by cutting off
uh just a little piece at the end
the
writer says some people say it's monday
each of the gospels if you read the last
chapter
they say something like this
if not exactly like this they say
in the end of the sabbath
as it began to dawn towards the first
day of the week
came mary and the others to the
sepulcher and of course they found that
jesus had risen
so all of the gospel writers agree that
what happened
happened the first day of the week right
which we know was
sunday morning right so the idea that
this happened on
monday or any other day is countermanded
by the word of god and all four gospel
writers agree yeah
okay so let's go to the next question
okay
i don't know there's much more as you
well know
uh there's there are several
considerations that we need to take into
account
the gospels use different expressions to
describe the time that jesus
went through his passion
i just like to mention some of those in
john chapter 2 verses 19 to 21
jesus said that he would rise in three
days
in mark 8 31 it says that he would rise
after three days
in matthew 16 verse 21 as well as other
verses it says
the third day
now there's no way that you can
reconcile all three of those if you're
dealing with strict chronology
and then of course you have the
controversial verse
uh actually versus matthew 12 39-40
where it speaks about being in the heart
of the earth
three days and three nights yes so now
if you take these expressions literally
there's no way you can reconcile them
the only way that you can reconcile them
is
if
you
use inclusive reckoning now
what is that ca what is inclusive
reckoning
it means you give credit for the full
day if any part of the day or greater
part of the day is included in the
prophecy or in the statement
and any portion of the night as well yes
day or night certainly right
now what evidence do we have in the
bible that that method of inclusive
reckoning is used i've heard a lot that
you know we need to use inclusive
reckoning but what evidence do we have
in other places of the bible that
inclusive reckoning is used yeah
there is
a bible verse that we find in luke 13.
luke 13
verse 32 and 33.
the gospel of luke 13 verses 32 and 33
and and this is
jesus speaking
and i'm going to read from the new king
james version
the bible says here
and he said to them go tell the fox
behold i cast out demons and perform
cures today
and tomorrow and the third day i shall
be perfected so here he is using today
tomorrow and then the third day but
notice what verse 33 says nevertheless i
must journey today
tomorrow and the day following
um or for it cannot be that our prophet
should perish
outside of jerusalem so notice that
jesus is using the day after tomorrow it
comes as a whole day the third day right
yeah and he's speaking on the on the
first day of the three exactly so when
he says
here
today
it wasn't right when the day was
beginning it was at some point during
the day
also you know the old testament uses
that method of reckoning
let me give you a couple of examples in
genesis chapter 7 verse 6
we're told that noah was 600 years old
when the flood came
but verse 11 says it was in the 600th
year of his life
so within the 600th year of his life
he's 600 years old
also
circumcision it's interesting that there
are texts that say
that a child was circumcised when he was
eight days old
another place says that
it was the eighth day and in other
places it says after eight days that's
right now there's no way you can
reconcile uh eight days old with after
eight days because after eight days
would be the ninth day
so so it's using in other words
inclusive reckoning
and
it's interesting
in luke 24
luke chapter 24
it deals with jesus walking to emmaus
with the two followers
and um
the afternoon of the third day
jesus supposedly resurrected
in the morning
of the third day but on the
afternoon of the third day it was still
the third day
because it says there in matthew chapter
25 excuse me luke 24
now behold two of them were traveling
that same day
to a village called village called
emmaus which is about seven miles from
jerusalem
but
uh and then they were they said we were
hoping that it was he who was going to
redeem israel indeed besides all this
today
is the third day since
these things happened
so
in the late afternoon
it's the third day still and supposedly
jesus resurrected exactly when the 72
hours came to an end
so clearly
you're dealing with inclusive records
there is another example in acts 10
verse 30 about cornelius
yes where he mentions four days
but actually the the visit or the answer
came in the ninth hour
and we have here
acts 10 verse 30. so cornelius said four
days ago i was fasting until until this
hour
and at the ninth hour i prayed in my
house and behold the man stood before me
in bright clothing
so
he takes it is the ninth hour but he
counts that as a whole day
yup
so the bible uses the method of
inclusive reckoning very clearly in many
different places we could mention other
examples as well but i think that the
point has been made
you know we we we find that strange and
i've heard many students of the bible
wrestle with this and struggle against
it
uh and that's because we have stop
watches we have clocks we've got our
computers here we can break up a day we
can segment a day down to the minute to
the second so we tend to focus on that
i'll see you at 3 30. right i won't say
i'll see you tomorrow 3 30. be there
i'll be there so we we do that but in
those times when you didn't have these
things you you were more general in your
time and i'll see you tomorrow that
could be tomorrow morning it could be
tomorrow afternoon but i know tomorrow
we will meet
uh so inclusive reckoning was part of
the mindset was part of the way that you
dealt with time that we don't do it
anymore like that yeah you know when
you're going to go on a cruise a
four-day cruise
uh is that just four complete days not
one minute more not one minute let's
know the day that you leave is one day
there's one day and you have two full
days and the third day you're back
so even today we use the method of
inclusive records indeed yes
so but here's the issue
there there's more to the story than
this
and the question is
is the heart of the earth the tomb
now how do we answer that is the
expression
that jesus was going to be in the heart
of the earth is that the same as the
tomb
no no not really no
and and that's where so many have sort
of slipped on this uh banana peel of a
verse because they've they they seen the
heart of the earth as the tomb uh having
been to the two places that they say
perhaps where christ has died uh where
he was buried the garden tomb
and uh the other one over by the bus
station basically in jerusalem neither
one of them are in the earth by the way
they're above ground
they're they're both above ground right
and and we're sealed by a stone so as
far as technically being in the heart of
the earth christ was never in the heart
of the earth he was above ground the
whole time sure yeah uh so we we really
begin to
have to look at the term heart of the
earth a little bit more
a little more precisely we can't just
say that as he went into the tomb that
he went into the heart and the fact is
that jesus knew the word grave or the
word tomb yeah
he could have said the son of man is
going to be in the heart of in the grave
three days and three nights
he knew the word grave because in john
chapter 5
verse 28
it says
jesus is speaking here do not marvel at
this for the hours coming in which all
who are in the graves will hear his
voice so jesus knew the word grave so if
the heart of the earth means the grave
why didn't jesus simply use grave rather
than the heart of the earth particularly
because he did not go to the heart of
the earth right literally speaking
really speaking uh may i share a verse
on the heart of the earth
and when we go to psalm
79 verse 20
we see here a hebrew parallelism and
uses a similar expression it uses the
depths of the earth
and notice how
the psalmist here the the salter license
it it says you who have shown me great
and severe troubles
shall revive me again
and bring me up again from the depths of
the earth
so it's interesting that that expression
is
used in connection
with an experience of severe trouble
severe tribulation
uh an experience or a moment when we
feel far from god
you know it's interesting that the
comparison that jesus draws
is a comparison with
jonah in the belly of the great fish
yeah it doesn't say the well we usually
say joe and i'm the whale but
you know the fact is
that
we need to understand and this is a very
very important point
that
the agony of jesus
actually began in gethsemane yes you
know you read
jonah chapter 2
john is alive
and he's praying to the lord alive
and he's afraid that god has forsaken
him let me just read a couple of verses
in jonah chapter 2 verse 1 it says then
jonah prayed to the lord
from the fish's belly
so he's alive
and then he in verse 2 it says and he
said i cried to the cried out to the
lord because of my affliction the niv
reads distress
and he answered me out of the belly of
sheol which is the grave and yet he's
alive he's alive
i cried and you heard my voice he's not
speaking as a dead person
his agony is while he is alive
and then you know you move on to verse 4
he says then i said listen to this
i have been cast out
the niv reads banished i have been
banished did jesus feel that when he was
in the garden of gethsemane
i have been cast out of your sight
yet i will look again
toward your holy temple so he says i've
been cast out but i know i'm going to
look upon your holy temple
and then in verse 6
he says i went down to the moorings of
the mountains that did not happen
literally
the earth with its bars
close behind me forever
yet you have brought up my life from the
pit yes so many peril is with jesus
uh you know so
i could continue other places
in verse 7 it says when my soul fainted
within me
or the niv reads when my life was ebbing
away but he's still alive
i remember the lord
and my prayer went up to you into your
holy temple
so very clearly
uh the experience of jesus in the garden
of gethsemane
must be included
in the three days and the three nights
indeed and that's i'm sorry i don't want
to cut you off but you just you know it
is no accident that christ used
the jonah and the fish story
it's
when we look at the word cardia
which is heart
it countenances not only
a
heart or central it countenances
feelings and emotions it's it's all
included in that word
so
the moment
christ began to suffer emotionally
uh you've got to put that time clock
back to thursday night uh and not friday
afternoon because he was in the control
under the control of evil men
he was under the sway of evil men he was
being punished mentally even before the
physical
pain began by evil men so you need to
push the clock back from friday evening
to thursday evening
and if you if you count inclusive
recording you get thursday you get
friday you get all day saturday and up
sunday morning so it does it does fit
and it does work you know the
interesting thing is
that
to go to the heart of the earth
would be the loneliest
darkest
and quietest place
that you could ever go good point
it's amazing the number of times that
ellen white uses the word darkness
and the fact that jesus felt
alone
and he cried out to his father and all
the response was silence
so the heart of the earth is simply a
metaphor
that means the furthest pay place
that you can get from god at that
particular point
and in the sacrificial system this is
very interesting in the sacrificial
system
when were the sins placed on the on the
animal
after the animal was dead
or while the animal was still alive
it was while he was still alive so
so the gethsemane is when the sins are
being placed upon jesus christ and he's
alive yes but then of course he dies
like the victim died
and uh and then resurrects from the
grave
so you know when you read the agony of
jesus in gethsemane and on the cross it
becomes very clear that he felt much
like jonah felt when he was in the belly
of israel you know when you look at this
daniel and pastor um
they slapped him they buffeted him they
pressed the crown of thorns this is all
pre-crossed you know this this is
leading up to the cross
the kind of
response he must have had to being
treated like that he knew what he was
going through and he knew what he was
headed to so he was in a very dark place
and that was that was real suffering it
wasn't imaginary it was physical mental
and of course spiritual suffering
occasioned by the knowledge that he was
carrying the weight of the world and it
was he was separated from his father uh
and then ellen white tells us that
he didn't know what was going to happen
on the other side
and when you don't know if you're going
to come out you're just following
through your relationship that's that's
darkness that's that's that's being in a
tough tough place and now i believe
there is another reason why jesus gave
that illustration of the the heart of
the earth the jonas sign
and it's because when you go to the book
of jonah
you see that
in the context of the book
um
it was actually that miracle
that helped the preaching of jonah in
nineveh and they believed
imagine like you come and you survived
being three days entry nice in the belly
of a fish and now you preach that uh if
you do not repent
you will receive the judgments of god
after such a miracle all these people
believed but jesus is saying
nina the ninevites believe the sign of
jonah but you won't believe
my sign of being three days and three
nights in the in the heart of the earth
and that's exactly the argument of
christ that is exactly the argument for
the ninevites
jonah was dead and resurrected
and
you know in luke 11 29-32 it says and
while the crowds were thickly gathered
together he began to say
this is jesus speaking this is an evil
generation
it seeks a sign
and no sign will give him be given to it
except the sign of the prophet jonah the
prophet
for as jonah listen here's here's the
key point for as jonah became a sign to
the ninevites
so also the son of man will be to this
generation and then of course jesus
argues that
nineveh repented
when they saw the sign
but that's wicked generation did not
have that even though jesus died and
resurrected it came from the tomb that's
the parallel that's that's a peril
exactly
what is interesting and we touched on
this before that if you if you back it
up until the time that he was taken in
the garden uh put into the hands of evil
men you've got your three
just about complete days you got
thursday night into friday evening along
with the first day one full day you got
friday night into sabbath second day and
then you've got saturday night into
sunday so you if if you're counting
hours you're only you're only shy three
days by a few hours yeah so he he
completed the prophecy he said what he
did what he said he was going to do you
have friday day
sabbath day
sunday day yes so you have three days
and three nights inclusively speaking
yes yes now there's another point which
is really interesting
and that is
that jesus himself included
his
arrest
and his trial
in the three days and three nights
let me just read a couple of a couple of
verses from scripture
the first of these is in mark 10 33-34
mark 10 33 and 34.
maybe i can have ca read that
okay
mark 10 33 33
oh goodness
okay
mark 10 33
behold we are going up to jerusalem and
the son of man will be betrayed
to the chief priests
and to the scribes and they will condemn
him to death and deliver him to the
gentiles 34 and they will mock him and
scourge him and spit on him and kill him
and the third day he will rise again so
it's all in the package yes yes so the
betrayal the condemnation the delivering
to the gentiles the mocking the
scourging the spitting on him and the
killing him yes are all included yes in
the three days so every night it is not
just the time when he was in the grave
precisely the whole
package of suffering so we've got to
start the clock ticking on thursday
evening
not friday afternoon when he was
betraying them and that is this by the
way is repeated in luke 18
31-33
uh it says there
then he took the twelve aside and said
to them behold we are going to jerusalem
and all things that are written by the
prophets concerning the son of man will
be accomplished for he will be delivered
to the gentiles and will be mocked and
insulted and spit upon they will scourge
him and kill him and the third day
he will rise
again
and a couple of statements from ellen
white this is youth instructor may 2
she wrote he who died for the sins of
the world was to remain in the tomb the
allotted time
now the question is what is the allotted
time we'll come back to that
he was in that stony prison house as a
prisoner of divine justice and he was
responsible to the judge of the universe
he was bearing the sins of the world and
his father only could release him now in
another statement this is a
manuscript the man of sorrows
typed february 24 1898 she describes
what the allotted time is
it was in god's plan that the work of
which christ had engaged to do should be
completed on a friday
and then on the sabbath he should rest
in the tomb
even as the father and the son rested
after completing their creative work
ellen white makes it crystal clear
that jesus completed his work he said it
is
it is finished
on the cross on friday
and he rested in the two months sabbath
and he would resurrect the first day of
the week that's the allotted time if you
take these two statements from ellen
white right yes yeah this quotation from
the bible in the book of mark backed up
by luke uh really makes it clear that
it's it's an inclusive
series of events not a segmented series
of events right yeah not only the time
that he that he was dead in the tomb
because then if you're going by strict
chronology 72 hours would have to be the
time
but the bible doesn't say 72 hours
i don't know but maybe we could read
just a couple of statements from ellen
white about the sufferings of jesus
actually i would recommend that everyone
read two chapters in desire of ages
one is gethsemane yes and the other one
is calvary
and so i want to read just a couple of
statements here i don't know how much
time we have left but
we should be pretty close to the end
maybe i'll just read one short one
the sins of men this is from the
chapters gethsemane the sins of men
weighed heavily upon christ
and the sense of god's wrath against sin
was crushing out his life
this is when he was in gethsemane
and there i have many other quotations
by the way if anyone is interested i
have full notes on this
and you know we'd be glad to share them
electronically with whoever wants them
that's that's powerful
his suffering began when they captured
him when they abused him it ended on the
cross but it was all part of the same
experience amen
yeah
well um
this is a very common question and i
think we have well
answered it we hope so
and thank you for sending your questions
to our program remember that you can
send them to tv at some tv dot org
and you can
send them there and we'll answer them
when
it's the time to answer them so god
bless you and thank you again for being
part of this program
[Music]
you